salut les menthe à l'eau dans la vidéo
numéro 244 avec romain de la chaîne
techno and test j'avais fait un battle
contre akinator ça m'a donné l'idée de
la vidéo du jour 250e sur 366 comme on
gagne à tous les coups qui s il ya
vraiment une astuce pour gagner au qui
est ce parce que la stratégie du ps elle
diffère pas trop de ce que j'ai fait
avec romain puisque on a tout un stock
d'information et on va vouloir faire un
tunnel pour trouver le plus rapidement
et le plus facilement possible
l'information aux questions parmi tout
ce choix un espèce de stock reading
mélangé à l'effet tunnel dans la
recherche d'infos l'idéal serait donc de
faire une dichotomie à chaque coup une
dichotomie est ce qu une dichotomie
c'est juste une division de partis ou
qui est classique à la base il ya 24
possibilité donc faudrait qu'on passe à
12 et puis ensuite à 6 et puis ensuite à
3 et puis ensuite à 2 et puis ensuite un
et la dame on gagnerait en cinq coups
mais c'est impossible parce que déjà il
n'y a rien qui permette aux pièces de
passer de 24 à 12 c'est à dire que le
créateur du ps ont séduit aura il a pas
il a une idée sympa mais ce n'est pas si
compliqué que ça à mettre en place
il a vraiment pensé à tout ça pour qu'on
puisse pas à la première question
éliminer la moitié du jeu ils sont
malins théo est roi parce qu ils sont
deux à avoir créé le jeudi qu'ils sont
et au et aura coster mais en étudiant
bien la question j'ai compris qu'on
pouvait gagner en six coups puisque de
toute manière on pourrait pas résoudre
le problème du premier coup de la
première dichotomie on peut pas le faire
on peut quand même gagner ensuite je
vais vous expliquer comment tout en
sachant que gagner ainsi coup ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir un facteur chance
en face le peut trouver un exemple en
disant que je pense que tu as machin il
a une chance sur 24 de réussir comme ça
mais dans le long terme vous serez
toujours plus souvent gagnant que
perdant en utilisant cette technique on
va utiliser des éléments qui sont très
peu utilisées dans les questions du
pièce on pense toujours un homme femme
ce genre de choses mais c'est pas
forcément les meilleures questions à
poser ma première question aux qui s c
est ce que la personne que tu as choisie
a des rides
si c'est oui alors il n'y a plus que
huit solutions différentes
si c'est non il n'ya plus que 16
solutions différentes et si la réponse
est oui vous allez gagner en 3 coups
maximum donc je vous fais le chemin
comme ça en passant par le côté reid
oui est ce que la personne a des rides
oui ensuite est-ce qu'elle est chaude si
c'est oui est ce qu'elle est des
lunettes et vous avez la réponse
l'autre possibilité avec les rides oui c
est ce qu elle a des rides oui est ce qu
elle est chouette non dans ces cas là
est ce que la personne est brun ou
brunes et là vous avez la réponse si la
réponse pour les rides et non alors
heureusement
c'est la personne à la défausse est des
jeux il faut celle ci la réponse est oui
alors vous demander à la personne si
elle a un chapeau et là vous avez
quasiment terminé et si la réponse est
non vous demandez c'est une fille
et là c'est quasiment terminée surtout
si c'est oui si c'est une fille si c'est
non il y aura sûrement une question en
plus à vous d'adapter la il reste
quasiment plus grand chose devant vous
j'ai pris aujourd'hui l'exemple du ps
mais c'est applicable à plein de choses
c'est applicable à même des choix qui
n'ont rien à voir ces mêmes applicable à
akinator ceux applicables à dénombrer
des chiffres vous pouvez le faire sur
rien juste dans ces cas là si vous
faites sur un objet n'importe quel objet
alors pensez toujours à réfléchir à des
choses qui vont vraiment concrètement
vous aider et les réponses qui vont vous
resservir même peut-être plus tard si
c'est un objet au lieu de demander si
ces gros ou petit demandé concrètement
est ce que ça tient dans la main est ce
que c'est le plus gros qu'un ballon de
foot chercher son utilisation et surtout
triché il a dit de tricher oui j'ai dit
de tricher mais de tricher
intelligemment c'est à dire pas tricher
pour tricher utiliser toutes les
réactions de non verbal de la personne
vous avez la personne qu en face de vous
donc vous pouvez utiliser toutes ses
réactions ses sourires son visage voyez
quelque chose que j'aime bien faire
c'est faire des affirmations ce faire je
n'utilise pas une question je donne une
affirmation je regarde juste la réaction
sur le visage si elle est plutôt positif
ou négatif et donc j'ai une réponse non
verbale et là je pose directement une
autre question
c'est pas très fair play comme drake
mais c'est légal ça rentre dans les
règles
si ça vous tente je peux faire aussi
d'autres astuces sur d'autres jeux de
société comme j'en avais déjà fait
d'ailleurs par le passé proposé mois
dans les commentaires des jeux auxquels
je pourrais parler évidemment il va y
avoir le poker faut que j'en reparle
j'en avais déjà parlé nous deux fois du
poker du black jack
je veux revenir aussi un petit peu sur
ce genre de jeu mais propose des mots
des jeux de société classique avec grand
plaisir
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si
elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas à me le
faire savoir en laissant un petit et
magnifique pouce en l'air faisait
longtemps que je l'avais pas vu comme ça
cela n'oubliez pas également de vous
abonner à la chaîne avant de partir et
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao